one afternoon in 1999 mr. Matsumoto had
an idea that idea would put his small
town of Susa me on the map
[Music]
this is mr. Matsumoto
he ran the post office in tsunami I know
that you are young you name although you
can get with it so that I did my stuff
yeah
and they da da da da no you know like
that era he'll be Umberto ah nice data
right Donna you thinkin what he deci
question in Aventura night in a classic
if you build it they will come story
they built it and people came hi Joe
Pistone yah Yama Yamaha sense aggregor
tokens are a famous this is mr.
nakanishi he runs the dive shop here in
Sioux Sami and he manages the postbox
hecho pastas ginger metal Renato Corona
además Pocono Chi Chi pasta Sakai chief
Kaito Coronado post Acosta
you mean theoretical Alison since the
box is underwater
you can't just mail a typical postcard
so it goes like this you come into mr.
nakanishi dive shop buy a postcard write
your note hi Joe Pistone ah ha ha ha
saying yo know
hi Swiss a no commute guitar Akio Scotty
muscle you say no magic could they hide
a muscle
gear up dive down slipped the note into
the red mailbox sitting on the ocean
floor and according to mr. nakanishi it
will actually get to its destination by
Nietzsche have a geocache you need the
muscle ok to post ogorodnik ieshua stay
in jamaat oh no you bikini - ok Tomas k2
pasta Sameach oh no oh no
hey Jose knows ice and Adam optimism
okay I pick the greatest omoimasu
ultimately mr. Matsumoto's idea worked
the mailbox made soo Sami a destination
for divers it made the town special guy
to bestow ah yes Osama key or no key
Kyoko's you know Coco taka me rotellini
Cheeta do this Haqqani dekiru
Tokoroa naka Takara media Cunha none of
the joke
[Music]
you